Intel arc graphics has finally arrived
at Enthusiast level grade with the debut
of the arc a770 and a750 delayed for
sure not without its issues absolutely
without making too many excuses for
Intel here we do need to remember that
this new third Player is taking on
incumbents in the graphics space with
Decades of experience where games have
been written exclusively for their
Hardware intel was never going to get it
completely right with its first attempt
but there's enough here to suggest
promising Beginnings though the scale of
the task in catching up with the
competition in Legacy games is I suspect
going to be a long-term project that
would take years to complete if it's
ever fully sorted at all so two products
to look at then supplied by Intel and
both limited editions or more accurately
reference boards I guess Founders
editions if you like both a750 and a770
are superb looking cards in my opinion
no garish color schemes no outlandish
cooler designs no Bizarro branding that
equates them to military-grade weapons
or sci-fi technology they're
fundamentally Back to Basics designs
that actually look for other great
slotted into your PC the a750 and a770
are essentially like for like in terms
of appearance but the a770 limited
edition here the 16 gig model comes with
RGB lighting that actually looks rather
pleasing as opposed to a pulsating RGB
nightmare reminiscent of a cheapo 90s
sound system both a750 and a770 are
built on Intel's Alchemist G10 dies so
it makes sense to normalize the form
factor Beyond RGB lighting they look
very similar indeed power is fed in Via
eight pin and six pin pcie inputs while
outputs consist of three display port
2.0s and one HDMI 2.1 there's little
more to comment on with regards to the
design of the card it's highly competent
I like the matte finish what else is
there to say
specs wise you'll find that the two
cards are quite similar not surprising
really as they use the same core chip
a770 is the fully enabled Alchemist G10
with the full complement of 32 XE cores
the option of 8 or 16 gigs of gddr6 vram
and 560 gigabytes per second of
bandwidth a750 scales down XE cores from
32 to 28 which in turn sees a similar
reduction in raid facing units and xmx
engines those xmx engines are
essentially Intel's take on nvidia's
tensor cores they process machine
learning tasks like the new xcss
upscaling Ram is limited to eight gigs
only on the a750 and bandwidth drops to
512 gigabytes per second aside from a
small reduction in average clock speeds
but they're pretty similar right so
we're going to be talking about
performance here and we're also debut
the beginnings of our new GPU Benchmark
Suite which also runs on a new platform
the core I9 10900k system of the last
couple of years gives way to the 12 900k
paired with g-skills impressive 6000
Mega transfer per second Trident Z5 ddr5
it's all running on an Asus Rog z690
hero motherboard and resizable bar rebar
is enabled and well for an Intel Arc
card it needs to be so here's the thing
our new benchmarking Suite is built
around new graphics apis established
engines and forward-looking features
raid facing is no longer a second class
Citizen and we aren't going to be
ignoring reconstruction techniques
either these are the few future of
gaming this is good news for Intel Arc
which works well with all of these
things but it does mean that these
titles will not highlight arc's
weaknesses let's put this plainly first
of all if your PC does not support
resizable bar do not buy Arc it'll be a
disaster rebar essentially gives your
CPU direct access to all Graphics memory
as opposed to the older system that
essentially uses a tiny 256 megabyte
buffer aux memory controller is built
around vbar no rebar no real performance
in most scenarios secondly Intel's
drivers are good to great for dx12 and
Vulcan apis but have issues with older
apis dx11 being highly contentious so
yeah in an Intel video I saw on Linus
Tech tips Linus himself showed Shadow
the Tomb Raider running under dx11 and
dx12 revealing very different frame
rates much lower on the older API as you
can see I've recreated this test with
more detailed Netflix across the
entirety of the bench dx12 is 15 faster
than dx11 no big deal right wrong frame
times are far more inconsistent with
dx11 resulting in obvious data more than
that some areas of the bench show much
bigger FPS disparities than other areas
dx12 can run up to two times faster than
dx11
so doesn't bode well for dx11 titles
right I think the variants will adjust
significantly according to content so in
a dx11 versus dx12 contesting remedies
control here dx12 is 15 to 18 percent
faster and fame Health consistency in
frame times is not that bad you'd want
dx12 obviously which is a bit of a
problem on this game which insists in
booting on Arc Hardware under dx11 only
unless you have a dx12 launch option
added to the executable there as you're
seeing here failing to do so not only
locks you out of the best performance
but also bars you from raid facing which
as you'll see Arc is actually very good
at so dx11 is at best inconsistent with
Arc at worst it's tantamount to the PC
graphics equivalent of a nuclear
disaster as you're seeing here with
Assassin's Creed Unity it's terrible
with the a770 and literally a slideshow
if you don't have resizable bar active
the RTX 3060 the Intel compares the a7c
70 with offers a 3.2 times performance
multiplier in performance here on
average rising to a 9.5 times multiplier
if your system does not have rebar even
the extremely unimpressive GTX 1650 is
40 faster this is essentially all down
to the poor driver really so dx11 rebar
pretty much a hellscape for arc when we
display frame rate metrics we use a nice
high resolution 60fps hero video for a
nice presentation but here's a look at
how Arc a770 with rebar on and off
actually looks though
very very Grim now we're about to see
that Arc is actually rather great on
Modern titles and the latest apis if you
have a rebar system but what's clear is
that dx11 is still a big problem from
what Intel has told us they're looking
to go back through the library and
optimize thing is which games need
optimization uh when will they be
optimized will they ever be optimized at
all the thing that bothers me about this
is that when it comes to Legacy titles
everyone has their favorites and they
can be pretty obscure I like Assassin's
Creed Unity because it was essentially
the last game in the series that stuck
to the original formula that tried to
deliver a next-gen experience for its
time but who's to say whether anyone
else agrees with me are there enough
people out there for Intel to say yep
let's sort this out and even if there
are what about the thousands of other
games a bunch of which may be your
favorite It's Tricky stuff and the
biggest negative point about Arc which
is a shame because there are plenty of
positives as we move into our new
Benchmark Suite dx12 or vulcan-based
games are mandatory in this lineup and
we kick off with cyberpunk 2077 using a
developer test Benchmark that zooms
around night City a bit more of a
workout than the standard bench sequence
accessible via the normal menus Arc a770
can't quite match RTX 3060 the Nvidia
card is about six percent faster at
1080p Arc 750 essentially offers 95 of
the performance of its bigger brother
I was scratching my head about which AMD
card to include and I eventually settled
on 6600 XT even though it's slightly
pricier it's comfortably ahead in many
games but I really wouldn't want to be
considering the base 6600 as it's not
really competitive in this field looking
at 1440p performance RTX 3060 drops back
and both Arc cards leap ahead not just
ahead of 30 60 but 6600 xt2 typically
the higher the resolution the better
arcs performance differentials as you'll
soon discover do maternal next to short
but sweet sequence here Arc a770 has a
Circa 20 point lead over 30 60 duking it
out with 6600
XT at 1080P and moving ahead at 1440p
again higher resolutions mean better
competitive performance do maternal is
so fast the RTX 3060 and the art cards
can deliver a great 4K experience
without any smart upscaling Technologies
involved and it's here where 6600 XT
drops back substantially Arc just Powers
ahead with a770 delivering a Circa 20
lead over 30 60. a 750 here just three
points off to 30 60. let's move on to
codemaster's f122 with the latest
iteration of the ever excellent ego
engine which sees the 6600 XT pull way
ahead of its competitors here and the
arc a770 also lags behind the 3060 which
is 10 faster in this scenario the a770
is about 7.5 percent faster of the a750
relatively small amount bearing in mind
the price differential the 3060s lead
over a770 drops to just 5 at 1440p but
the 6600 XT is still considerably ahead
so we've got another example here of Arc
becoming more competitive at higher
resolutions and so at 4K Arc a770
catches up with 3060 and the 6600 xt's
lead drops to just three percent it was
a 23 lead at 1080p so yeah interesting
stuff frame rates are in the 50s here at
4k on absolute Max settings so it's not
as if these cards can't deliver this
game but a good performance level at 4K
native
Forza Horizon 5 extreme settings and
other strong showing here from all of
these cards RTX 3060 slots in between
Arc a750 and a770 on aggregate the 3060
is seven points clear of a750 while the
a770 as well seven points clear of 30
60. uh Radeon 6600 XT is notionally the
most expensive card here but delivers
really good performance especially at
1080P and 1440p again Arc moves up the
pecking order at 1440p almost hitting
6600 XT perf levels beating 30 60 by 11
and where this time the a750 is snapping
at the heels of the 3060.
a very quick look at gears 5 here again
arcs relative competitive performance
gets better at higher resolutions but
3060 is still comfortably ahead at 1440p
and 6600 XT remember notionally the most
expensive card in the lineup here well
that still retains its lead
we've got a few more titles to look at
before we move on to raid facing
performance where Arc proves to be more
surprising but first up the rasterized
version of Hitman 3. the Dubai Benchmark
here shows a750 and a770 capable of
beating RTX 3060
a 4 and 10 lead respectively a770 nips
at the heels of the 6600 XT here so
perhaps unsurprisingly when we moved to
1440p RTX 3060 is left for dust a750 now
matches 6600 XT and a770 is four points
ahead I'm sure you can't fail to have
noticed at this point that the a750 is a
good performer here right yes it's cut
back in Spec terms but it holds its own
with actual frame rates not far off its
larger sibling
Arc continues to show its potential in
Red Dead Redemption 2. The Benchmark
here throwing up some remarkable results
Arc a770 doesn't just trounce the RTX
3060 is actually 10 faster than the RTX
3060 TI both Arc a750 and a770 leave the
competition way behind here even at
1080p at 1440p the 3060 TI inches ahead
of the a770 but it's still in the
running a really nice result for Arc
here finally an anti-climactic result
with Shadow the Tomb Raider where we
return to something approaching
normality at 1080p with the a770 closely
matching RTX 3060 the 6600 XT inching
ahead however that scalability the arc
chips Rising nicely with an increase in
resolution and happens again with Arc
a770 at 1440p Five Points clear of the
6600 XT while the a750 is on par with
RTX 3060. that scalability actually
continues at 4K where the 3060 continues
to match the a750 but now the a770
commands a 24 lead over the 6600 XT
interesting results overall there I'd
say that Arc is holding its own in
modern games with modern engines that
said the configuration of the chip in
terms of transistor count and frequency
would suggest that it should be
competing more often with the 3060 TI
and maybe even 3070 but still not bad
for the price I'd say the scaling of the
Chip's performance with resolution also
intrigues me I'm thinking that maybe the
driver is still holding it back to a
certain degree at lower resolutions with
each leap in resolution the balance
between driver performance and silicon
performance shifts more towards the
hardware seemingly delivering better
results against the competition
let's move on to raid facing where Intel
is promising better than Nvidia class
performance at least based on the chat
Alex and I had with Tom Peterson a few
weeks back and you know what he may well
have a point No Holds Barred with the
first test here cyberpunk 2077 Ultra RT
not quite psycho RT but still a very
tough workout raid facing really does
need serious work on the AMD side
hopefully with much improved performance
in the upcoming rdna 3 cards here the
mid-range Rd and A2 offering is well off
the pace set by the competition frame
rates are low yes but at 1080p RTX 3060
is ahead of the arc offerings however
Arc a750 here isn't just beating RX
6600xt according to our stats it's
within margin of error of RX 6700 XT
performance
moving on to 1440p Arc a770 moves ahead
of the 3060 6600
XT is now in slideshow territory it's
worth pointing out of course that Nvidia
has dlss to fall back on and we're still
waiting for FSR 2.0 and xcss to be
implemented on this one but you know a
promising star for Arc then so let's up
the ante with Alex batalia's Corridor of
Doom as found in remedies control
notorious for its sheer brutality on
Hardware particularly on AMD RT Hardware
Intel actually puts in an excellent
showing here at 1080p a750 15 ahead of
the 30 60 and 42 points ahead of 6600 XT
a770 an impressive 50-point lead over
6600 XT and a 21 advantage over RTX 3060
Arc a770 kinda sits between 30 60 and 30
60 TI RT performance in this one at
1440p the performance differentials
between Arkham 3060 are pretty much the
same but AMD Falls even further behind
Arc a750 is now 15 points ahead of the
6700 XT not plotted here it's 55 ahead
of 6600 XT which is shown here returning
to the rain-soaked Singapore circuit in
f122 this time Nvidia takes point at
1080p with both a770 and a750 trailing
by 15 and 11 respectively and the 6600
XT puts in a stronger showing here it's
just six points off the a750 you know
the script by now though right at 1440p
a770 is nipping on the heels of RTX 3060
and in fact although not plotted here
the 6700 xt2
we're going to end with a couple of
titles that demonstrate that Intel's
commitment to rate facing is certainly
impressive and it's up there with the
Nvidia competition if not able to exceed
it Hitman 3 return to the Dubai stage
the cheaper a750 matches RTX 3060
performance very closely on average it's
about three points off the pace but what
I find interesting is how 3060 can beat
a 750 and vice versa depending on the
scene being rendered however in all
scenarios a770 is the fastest car of the
lot remarkably a770 is 25 faster than
a750 23 faster than 30 60. it's 94
points ahead of RX 6600xt it gets better
at 1440p too where the a770 is even more
dominant and the a750 inches ahead of
RTX 3060
finally Metro Exodus enhanced Edition
it's the first AAA game released that
Demands a card that supports Hardware
accelerated rate facing it was built
from the ground up not just to work with
raid facing but to run well on the
consoles which are using rdna2 Graphics
remember
so we do get good performance on AMD but
we get even better performance on Nvidia
ampere and well better still RT frame
rates to Mark even at 1080p Arc a770
bounces over 30 60 to the point where
it's as fast as the 3060 TI a750 is 25
faster than 30 60 and 53 points ahead of
the RX 6600 XT meanwhile a770 increases
that lead over the 3060 to 34 it is 64
faster than 6600 XT and actually beats
the 6700 XT by 25
remarkable stuff a sneak peek at 1440p
performance here where the frame rates
may be lower but the performance
differentials are even wider so here
a770 beats 3060 by 45 and it's almost 73
ahead of the 6600 XT
not much to say here except that well
I'm impressed the core RT performance is
there but what Arc doesn't have at the
moment is the same kind of acceleration
provided by dlss on the Nvidia side
which actually turns out to be supported
in all of the raid facing titles in our
Benchmark Suite what we need is more
support for xcss which will hopefully be
coming in due course and has proven to
be an excellent quality upscaler time
was limited with Arc we only had around
five days to produce this review so we
couldn't test xcss to anything like the
degree we wanted to but in gameplay
terms Arc a770 could easily run shadow
of the Tomb Raider locks at 4K in xcss
performance mode RT proved a little too
much for it though with frame rates
dropping into the 50s still though this
is a 1080p 1440b class card and xcss
could put supported titles into 4K
territory and that's good titles that
run well anyway also benefit of it
tremendously as you might imagine
they're stranding even in its taxing
infoscene 4K 60 locks no bother we did
run a short Benchmark with xcss
performance mode at 4K with both Arc
products up against rzx 3060 with dlss
set to equivalent settings interesting
stuff here if you saw Alex's video
you'll know that RT is very heavy on the
GPU in this title looks like Arc a770
comfortably outscores the 30 60 here
Circa 40 faster overall I reckon which
is pretty impressive once again Arc a750
trades blows with the 3060. sometimes it
is faster sometimes it is slower but as
an average across the bench frame rates
about 10 percentage points to the better
overall so I guess if arc's RT Hardware
is good it stands to reason that xcss
acceleration Builds on that and this
Birds well for the future I'd say so
let's wrap everything up then Arc is a
game of two halves I'm impressed with
the pricing I'm also rather happy about
its performance on Modern titles and I'm
really taken aback by the rate facing
turnout too with two of the three firms
concentrating on strong RT performance
it means the AMD must surely respond all
eyes will be on rdna3 where we hope to
see great things just bear in mind that
Graphics architectures take years to
develop right we can't expect miracles
and that goes equally for Arc 2 because
as much as I'm loving the performance
from our core benchmarks I just don't
know what to make of the support for
Legacy games depends on how important
that is to you I guess more than that
I'm not really sure how Intel wants to
address this issue we need some kind of
road map a title by title plan perhaps
dx11 can't be left in the state it is
now though that's for sure so highs and
lows for Arc but overall I'm coming out
of this one fairly optimistic there's
genuine value here there's strong
performance in modern games but still
the sense that there's more to come in
terms of driver updates out of all of
the cards tested today which one would I
buy
that's tricky But ultimately Nvidia has
Legacy titles support sorted it has dlss
it has decent raid facing the 30 60
isn't a bad buyer MSRP 6600
XT
excellent raster performance the Legacy
game support is obviously there but raid
facing just isn't competitive so that
leaves Arc obviously the first step in a
long journey for Intel but it does land
some blows against the incumbents and
does deliver what Intel said it would
then there's the huge freebie game pack
they're giving away to including Modern
Warfare 2. helps to make these cards a
more compelling package oh and one more
thing there are two
a770s to choose from as I said earlier 8
and 16 gig variants for the extra 20 the
extra Ram is probably worth having but
that's all from me for now so yeah like
subscribe share there's the bell of
course for ringing which allegedly
offers instant notifications uh DF
supporter program join us join our
brilliant Community get high quality
video downloads and yeah maybe four
unedited benchmarks from this video to
peruse too and do check out will Judd's
excellent text review for Eurogamer all
of the video capture data used for the
benchmarks you've seen in this video
they plug straight into the website and
if you like bar charts that's where
you'll see that data presented in that
form but that's it from me for now
thanks for watching and supporting
digital Foundry